si le comienza a escribir una nueva
página de su historia con la llegada de
los 155 convencionales constituyentes
aquí a la sede del congreso chileno
donde tendrá lugar la ceremonia de
inauguración parte el que se empieza a
descontar el reloj de cuenta atrás para
escribir una nueva constitución tendrán
un plazo de nueve meses prorrogable por
tres meses más en un año total para
escribir una constitución una nueva
carta magna destinada a reemplazar a la
heredad por la dictadura de augusto
pinochet en 1980 es una ceremonia en la
que se deberá elegir al presidente o
presidenta al vicepresidente o la
vicepresidenta a través del método
seleccionado por los propios
convencionales constituyentes así que no
sabemos cuánto va a demorar este proceso
ni cuánto va a durar lo que sí es que la
mañana ha estado muy tranquila a pesar
de que los distintos puntos de la
capital había convocadas hasta cuatro
manifestaciones y también marcadas por
las ceremonias distintas ceremonias de
los diez pueblos originarios que existen
en el país y que están representados con
17 escaños en esta convención
constituyente esto marca un precedente
importante en este nuevo chile que se
quiere construir y en el qué
pueblos originarios tendrán un rol y una
voz muy importante en esta primera
ceremonia de inauguración no participará
ninguno de los otros poderes del estado
tras la polémica en las últimas semanas
sobre la injerencia o no del gobierno en
este proceso chile comienza hoy a
escribir así su nueva constitución